Hello, this is Frank Defratis, and welcome to another week of Holo Talk for the week of March nineteenth 2000.
I'm joined in the studio right now with Michelle Roy, who's sort of becoming a sidekick with the Holo Talk Show.
Oh, thank you.
The trustee sidekick, like Batman and Robin.
Batman and Robin, yeah, Frank and Michelle.
Okay.
We have a number of special broadcasts that's coming up for you over the next few weeks.
We visited the Center for Holographic Arts in New York City, actually Queens, right?
That's where it was.
And uh they had their opening there with a number of their artists in residency uh program students works that were on display.
And we had an opportunity to interview a number of the people who were uh represented in that show.
So over the next few weeks we're going to be uh bringing you uh these programs, and Michelle uh joined me in New York City to uh interview them as well.
And Michelle, I have no idea what I want to ask you.
Well that should work well.
Basically, why don't you tell the listeners we know you've been on the Holo Talk Show before you do a special on careers?
Um, why don't you take a minute to uh tell the listeners what it is that we'll be doing together when we do programs together.
What do you mean?
Well ask me that question differently.
Say for instance someone comes to see us do a program.
What would it be?
What would this be when they come to see us?
My interest in all of this is uh related to um careers and lasers and holography and photonics is in terms of um how they can turn into careers for people.
So for example, when we went to uh Queens yesterday, uh you were talking to people about more of the, you know, technical aspect of what they were doing and um the artistic uh pieces of it, although I like to talk about the artistic parts too.
Uh but you did a very nice job.
Oh, thank you.
Yes.
Thank you.
But my uh major interest is in w what makes someone want to do this, what makes someone want to go into uh holography, what kinds of mental disorders.
Exact exactly.
Trying to identify mental disorders.
I was I am trying to hook people up with some psychiatric, you know, resources if necessary.
No, just you know, finding out what what interests people about the field, what do they enjoy about the field, what kinds of opportunities are out there.
Uh some of the people that we spoke with yesterday talked about like internship possibilities and uh artists in residence programs and so forth, classes that you can take that, you know, let people who are interested in pursuing it a little more uh deeply have an opportunity to get some different kinds of experiences and if they want to turn it into a career, then you know, there there would be a way to do that.
So that was more my take on um what what we were doing and and why we were there, which when we do programs together, that's where I fill in as well is looking at how people can turn what is obviously a passion.
I mean that came through loud and clear in all of the interviews that we did yesterday that people do this because they really love it.
Um and I'm in a b a big believer in um taking the things that you really love to do, figuring out how to make some money off of it.
So you know, that's basically uh sort of the approach I was taking.
Do you think people basically mention their passion because they don't make a lot of money?
I'm sure that's part of it.
I mean, particularly I mean we were talking to artists, so you know, um people who are are not using lasers in like an industrial setting or something like that where it might be a little bit different and you have business driving it so that there is money.
Um, yeah, I would say that those people probably, you know, they have to be driven by something because it's it certainly wasn't money, um, that it is, you know, the love of the field.
The way that I use holography in a lot of the workshops that I do is not so much to allow people to move on and become holographers as it is to turn them on to what lasers can do uh as far as uh communication technologies and and things of that nature where they could go out and get a very high paying job because there's quite a demand for people who are skilled in that field.
Well see the thing that I thought was interesting about yesterday was I I am more in many ways more aware of you know lasers in terms of using it in communications and that sort of thing, more of that business kind of field.
And the thing that was fun about yesterday was talking to people who are artists, you know, and who use you know who who really see the hologram as the thing.
Yeah.
Um so that was just sort of a different, you know, perspective.
And holography is a great way to get people to come in and experience lasers.
Sure, right.
Yeah, I mean you could bring someone into a classroom or someone into a workshop and just teach them about lasers.
But holography is a wonderful way to combine a lot of different elements of learning and at the same time l allow them to get experience with lasers.
And so much more constructive than shining laser pens in.
Uh we have a program coming up where you can come and see Michelle and I at the Smithsonian on May 6th.
And uh we're going to have an exhibit of holograms there, and we'll be doing uh presentations throughout the day.
At the Hershawn Museum.
At the Hershawn Museum uh of the Smithsonian, which is right on the mall.
And uh we'll have more information on that as uh time goes on.
But uh over the next few weeks you're going to be hearing some programs that Michelle and I put together while we were in New York and that will sort of lead us up to the uh the programs that we will be running at the Smithsonian in Washington coming up on May 6th, and that's the program for uh for the public.
We also have another program coming up for uh a national teachers conference that will be there as well.
So let's move on to the interview.
Our first guest on the show in this series is uh one of the co-directors of the Center for Holographic Arts, Anna Maria Nicholson.
And uh we also have a link to the uh Center for Holographic Arts webpage that you can click on that and visit their website as well.
So let's move on to the interview.
Michelle, thank you very much for uh coming into the studio and going on the trip.
And those of you out there in Holo Talk Land will be hearing more from Michelle and uh you'll hear me shut up a little bit more and let her talk a little bit more, which many of you may be grateful for.
So let's move on to the interview and we'll see you next week.
A new show each week.
Don't forget to tune in.
See ya.
Hi, this is Frankie Freitas.
I'm here in Long Island City, better known as Queens, right?
And we have the opening of the Holo Center's exhibit.
Is this the uh in fact I have Anna Maria Nicholson with me now?
How are you?
Fine, thank you.
The Center for the Holographic Arts.
Center for the Holographic Arts, okay.
Short version for the internet.
The website is HoloCenter.com, right?
Exactly.
And we'll have a link to that on the web page so people can go visit that site while they're listening to the show.
Okay, great.
Why don't you take a moment to tell us a little bit about some of the pieces that are on exhibit here and we'll get back and also ask you about the programs that you have here as well.
Well we're extremely pleased.
With this is our very first exhibition uh for the artists uh who received the Artists in Residency program.
And this is the first year.
And it's amazing to us how good the work is and what a b uh to me especially uh well all of the work but Mary Harman's work um is a really breakthrough for holography I think the fact that the holograms come off the wall and become part of of an installation and part of the and they're extremely beautiful.
She did them all here.
And that beautiful work could not have been created without the center.
That's why I feel that we are doing a very good job as far as providing this opportunity for artists to come and work.
How long has the center been here?
We this is our second year and we are funded for one more yeah and after that we hope to continue to be funded further but we don't know yet.
Now you do post portraits here as well right yes yes we do a post portraits and also um jobs uh on commission for um trade shows and things like that that that helps us with the with the um money situation here so I'm assuming that anyone can come in or contact the studio here and say I'd like to have a portrait done of myself or my family or anything like that right?
Absolutely I've been doing portrait as you know for God knows how many years and it has been uh you know was sustained me as far as uh financial situation in holography and now the center is continuing with that and I do the portraits with and Dan too, you know, we were both collaborating.
And uh you can make an appointment.
It's very reasonable, a thousand dollars for the portrait.
And um that's all it takes.
What what size spinal reflection hologram is that when it's finished?
It's about it's eleven twelve by fourteen.
That is correct.
Yeah.
Um is this the first exhibit that you have had here for your artists in residency program?
Yes, this is the very first and we plan to have one every year for the artist of that year o of the of the past year.
Now I know you have a program here.
Have you reviewed any applications for your next AIRs here?
Not yet.
Uh because uh when when we have the uh the deadline is July fifteenth.
So no we have received hardly any applications yet, although we are very open to everyone.
As far as the gallery goes, if someone happens to be in the New York City area, can they come over here to Queens and just come in and see the exhibit?
They can if they uh telephone f ahead of time.
And also this exhibition is only going to be here for two weeks.
Then it's going to travel down to a gallery in Fort Myers in Florida and from there it's going to go to the Tucson Museum of Contemporary Art.
So that uh we're very pleased that it's doing the round.
Okay.
I'm going to turn the microphone over to Michelle Roy who's here with us today.
Hi Michelle how are you doing?
Good Frank how are you?
We're doing more and more work together in holography and lasers.
That's right.
So uh here's the microphone and here's Michelle Roy.
Um actually what I uh am interested in in my uh background in is in um helping people decide on careers and what they want to do with their lives.
So what interests me about all of this is how do you decide to go into holography?
What made you decide to uh to do this?
Well, for me personally a and as with so many other first wave or second wave holographers, we saw a hologram and we fell in love with it and said this is the purpose of our life, you know.
Uh some to our great regret later, but you know it's a very, very difficult medium.
It's a wonderful medium, very expensive medium.
Um at the moment uh we are very fortunate to have two assistants who just walked off the street practically, who are now um helping us and extremely interested in continuing holography as uh their artistic medium.
So do you consider yourself a an artist or a technician or both?
No, I'm an artist and I have had uh uh shows and in in our galleries and so on.
Um so what made you decide to work in this medium?
Um is this the only medium that you work in?
And it okay.
What attracted you to to this as opposed to you know being a painter or a sculptor or I don't know, it was a wonderful medium.
It's a magical the fact of of reality being there and not being there, a space that is illusory.
Um that's the whole thing is uh it's a dreamscape basically that we can explore and create in.
And I'm now extremely excited because I'm about to start a whole new series with uh a a model that I have who's now coming from Paris and to have a a figure coming through veils, coming through smoke, coming through to uh from one reality to another.
Now I was speaking earlier to um your intern um who is here and um talking to yes.
Um can you tell me about your internship program and how that works?
Uh how uh you know, someone who might be interested in getting involved in holography might be able to um you know participate through the internship.
Well we're extremely open to Makiko found us on the internet, you know, as you she probably told you she came from Japan to study holography.
Uh we we don't in our budget we don't can't pay so but we what we do is we teach them holography.
We the the equipment is there for them um and we help them and encourage them and teach them also in not only holography but art.
You know Dan and I are old hands in there so what kinds of um things is is she is Makiko learning how to do?
Whether can you give me an idea of sort of the for lack of a better word the curriculum although that sounds a little too you know structured maybe.
It is too structured.
Um she's here she helps us for whatever we need to do because we do quite a lot of shooting.
Um she's now totally expert as as far as the dark room is concerned.
She's helping us set up uh in the CW table and she's helping us with the pulse um shooting.
What I want to do when we have uh a w a week or two free is have her create her own hologram now.
I think it's time and then we'll help we'll walk her through the the process the process.
So if someone were interested in obtaining an internship they would just need to to contact you.
Okay and and you interview them and do a little bit of checkup and uh if they are sympathical with us uh and vice versa then we have two now one is David uh Baraski and this is this hologram here is one of his and uh we are very uh pleased and amazed this is a th his third hologram in his life very sophisticated.
He's a student at um NYU and he just again fell in love with holography.
And he I think he's thinking of holography as his his medium as a major medium.
What's the I was just saying okay for what she was saying.
Oh okay.
Well you made me lose my train of thought now.
Yeah he's sorry that I'm making him now have to go in and cut this all out.
I might just leave it in.
This is what the listeners like this though.
Oh all right the banter back and forth.
Um so if someone were thinking about holography, what would you encourage them to do?
If if the kid is in you know high school or in college, what are the kinds of things that they would need to to do to go on the way, um go to Frame is and check out the other websites.
Um I don't know of any other well Dan gives private lessons uh he could they could do that they could contact us.
Uh and I don't know I think that the School of Visual Arts has um course in holography.
I don't know of anything else.
Okay.
So there are some some programs that are out there where the kids could take courses or students could take some courses um but this may be the only place where they could completely focus on holography.
Don't forget that uh the great advantage that we have is that we have a pulse laser.
And uh with a pulse laser which is uni I think there is one in uh San Francisco there may be another one somewhere in the country but we're very few.
And with uh that opens up a whole new um uh themes uh for for the young artist uh and the all the ease of making a hologram and and the fact that you can use human beings and and you know.
So I think that's our very, very unique and by the way, people we we do rent the pulse per per day very reasonable, seven hundred and fifty dollars a day and with all our help.
Right.
Yeah.
So if somebody wanted to come in and try it out and and see, you know, uh how to create their own h hologram that they could come in here and do that.
Precisely and also if then they want to transfer it there also we can also help them with that.
Great.
I appreciate it.
Thank you very much.
Uh I Okay, I think what we'll do is get someone else in and then we'll just continue with the show.